jack
hello
i only been a firefighter five years you
like it love it
you one of those gung-ho guys run into
the burning building no fear
running the burning building while guys
like you're running out screaming like
little girls
[Applause]
horses are red violets are blue on our
wedding night my husband what
we went to bed
a man falls out of your boat and into
the water you should yell man overboard
now what should you yell if a woman
falls overboard full speed ahead
how would you change rj
major plastic
all right he's surgery major plastic
surgery here how would you change your
six foot understood
name something couples do to spark up
their marriage
how about
get together with other couples
[Applause]
what do i mean i just mean that uh
not talk
playing term that means wife
[ __ ]
if you were a detergent
what would your slogan be
the harder you rub the
cleaner i come
[Applause]
p
there is a p
people your time starts now
a group of pill pushers
[Applause]
goodnight everyone thank you
[Applause]
this is wheel of fortune joe has it
always been difficult getting
women with that red hair
no no i've been very successful
romantically ann um even at your size
absolutely don't pretend that you don't
want a piece
something your neighbor has you wish you
had
a beautiful wife
what is there about your daughter that
reminds you of yourself when you are
dating
well
there is not too much that reminds me of
myself when i was dating
except maybe she likes to park
how long have you known this oh for at
least two years
how does a girl earn a little star in
your little black book
uh when she uh puts her hand in my
pocket and grabs my rocket and shoots
the stars
what will your husband say is the one
thing he absolutely forbids you to put
on his wiener
ben gay
complete this sentence
this may sound a little weird but
i am naked right now
something you wouldn't try even once
matthew
sex on a train
other than popcorn what is your favorite
thing to nibble on at the movies
steve
i'm gonna get shot uh
her boobs i don't know
we asked a hundred women named something
women borrow from each other chris one
of those husbands they're husbands
gentlemen tell me what is your favorite
part of our newlywed game set
jim
probably a wife number two
oh is the generic word for any living
animal or plant including bacteria and
viruses
orgasm
[Applause]
there
there are reasons
there are reasons which i won't go into
that i can't accept that
electricity in our home flows from the
blank to the what from the plug to the
vibrator
why did the two of you make whoopee when
you did for the very first time sharon
[Applause]
how long did your very first kiss as
husband and wife last
it better be five seconds five seconds
she said it lasted it lasted it lasted
45 seconds 25 seconds that was my
brother
man of the world traveled all over the
world something russia is famous for bob
russians
and something that can kill a lively
party
name something that follows the word
pork you pie
huh
[Applause]
name a part of the body that gets bigger
as adults get older
freddy penis
remind us how you tried to kill him i
poisoned you didn't i was it that well
you tried that and then you got a
shotgun and then i got a shotgun i
dressed up like cher and then i got a
shotgun and shot him
and you're still looking like cher
[Music]
well she looks good for her age unlike
some people
[Music]
things would you like to change on your
body
my legs for one what's wrong with your
legs well they're kind of short
that's okay good things come in little
packages sure especially what's in
between them
number two one of my worst subjects is
spelling could you tell me how do you
spell relief
f-a-r-t
motorcycle journalist from westchester
new york and i'd love to talk to you
about the amateur lingerie contest that
you were in may i ask what kind of
lingerie were you supporting that day it
was a nice thought
so you're gonna have to stop now because
i got to continue and
more minutes later
keep talking i'll be done before we're
ever done here
claim something a man has that he'd be
upset
if someone else used it
how about his jock strap
someone else use my jock strap
name something that falls from the trees
jackie about
bird
got it right it does happen
boy i'm glad cows don't
though most planets are named after
roman deities what is the only one named
for a figure in greek mythology
venus jupiter saturn uranus
jupiter
is
roman i believe
i can't even put a finger on uranus
[Music]
a world-renowned sculptor wants to do a
full-length sculpture of you to be
displayed in a public place the only
requirement is that you'll be absolutely
naked
would
you
do it
janet what's gary going to say
i'd say no all right let's bring him on
and find out
if i can make it there i'd make it
anywhere what city are we talking about
jimmy
phoenix